tonight we start with news that was a
shock to so many the passing of Kelly
Preston
she really was one of our favorite stars
to cover our hearts break for John
Travolta who has suffered yet another
devastating family loss life was too
short gotta live it never get romantic
get things like this right now it's
behind the bleachers I love this
beautiful lady Kelly had kept her
diagnosis private but last night her
husband John Travolta shared the sad
news quote my beautiful wife Kelly has
lost her two-year battle with breast
cancer 20 year old daughter Ella called
Kelly courageous and wrote thank you for
being there for me no matter what
[Music]
Kelly's kids were everything and her
last Instagram post was this a family
selfie honoring John for Father's Day
she also shared this photo of Travolta
with their late son Jett who died in
2009 after a seizure at the family's
vacation home in the Bahamas
[Music]
Kelly and John introduced us to jet on
the set of look who's talking now in
1993 he went to the aquarium and he
learned how to talk to the beluga whales
so now Kelly and John met more than
three decades ago in 1987 while filming
the movie the experts their connection
was obvious et was there as they joked
around promoting the movie we're here in
the experts we're at the Hard Rock they
married in 1991 and over the years
supported each other's growing careers
two weeks ago as Kelly's turn now it's
my turn
so we're gonna keep you guys busy for
the next you know 20 years this is I
guess maybe a little different now
because you're being brought along to
Kelly's big movie well it's nice
actually the 57 year old was a devoted
Scientologist just like John
she told et how a Scientology
purification ritual changed her life I
had done drugs earlier a long time ago
and those things came out to mean there
was possibly just a slight haze maybe
that I was living through it just just
and it wasn't really noticeable until I
had gotten out of it which was kind of
wonderful this was Kelly's last public
appearance for the movie gaudy it was in
2018 which would have been around the
time of her breast cancer diagnosis
Kelly also walked the red carpet and can
with John and the kids for the film she
played the wife of her husband's
character John Gotti people have been
really excited it's been really special
Kelly glowed on screen and her light
shined off-screen as well he's a
sweetheart he's got a great sense of
humor and he doesn't take himself
serious
that was Kelly's first et interview she
was just 26 and was thrilled to have
gotten the role of Arnold's girlfriend
in the blockbuster twins I baked you
some cookies today
Arnold posted her talent was off the
charts she had such a big heart yes it's
true he's a great kisser it was a lot of
fun Kelly started 50 movies the
fresh-faced girl from Hawaii was always
playful when we visited her set
everything when you look at you you're
talking to entertainment st. Nick
gravel-pit
so glamorous hello
proud to be a working mom Kelly would
often bring jet to set he loves this set
to cuz there's huge spaces there's that
scaffolding I've got my trailer here so
yeah I know four year old climbing up on
the scaffolding she starred opposite
Kevin Costner in the baseball classic
for love of the game all I've got it's
my toothbrush and a bathing suit I
bought at the airport he's very playful
and fun but he's also very serious money
and did Jerry Maguire Kelly had a steamy
makeout with Tom Cruise watching love
scenes was always difficult for John
want anything from the kitchen I'm gonna
get some fruit when we went to the
premiere he kept thinking he was gonna
like close his eyes but he didn't and he
sat there said oh it's okay whoo you
know I got through that he was fine with
it
when daughter Ella followed her parents
into acting Kelley was bursting with
pride dream come true yeah really yeah
it was the perfect you can't even call
it a job it was it was so much fun it
was perfect family movie I was so
excited when I heard that they were
gonna be into I was like just but it
wasn't just films that's Kelly in maroon
5's video she will be loved Adam Levine
cast her admitting he had a bit of a
crush
it as for Kelly's philosophy throughout
her life she kept it simple just a good
work I mean I think that's what anybody
wants keep the family together and happy
and just enjoy life
[Music]